buenas tardes gracias por estar aquí por
compartir estos momentos de viernes de
octubre como si fuera septiembre o frost
si fuera agosto casi la charla que os
voy a dar hoy a espero que cambie
nuestra visión de cómo tomáis decisiones
que cambie como creéis que toma estas
decisiones como de consistentes sois en
vuestras decisiones de acuerdo y nos
vamos a fijar en como el lenguaje y
veréis a lo que me refiero realmente
puede hacer que seamos menos
consistentes de lo que realmente creemos
que somos de acuerdo pero antes de
entrar en ello y creo que en esta
audiencia tal vez no sería necesario
dejadme que os explica un poco la
situación del conocimiento de lenguas
eso es un mapa de europa en el que
encontramos las zonas rayadas aquellas
zonas donde hay dos lenguas propias
conviviendo de acuerdo a quién está el
inglés como lengua frame a franca se lo
pusiéramos estaría todo rayado entonces
esto lo que viene muestran
que la mayoría de la gente más del 50 de
la gente habla dos lenguas se comunica
en dos lenguas
no es una cuestión realmente especial lo
mejor si estáis en birmingham es
especial si eres inglés si eres indio
ciertamente no vienes de cualquier otra
cultura no y cuando vas a otros países
especialmente a otros continentes como
es el áfrica es realmente lo normal lo
normal es ser capaz de comunicarse en
marte una lengua y de hecho no es una
experiencia que venga con la
globalización no tiene nada que ver con
la globalización es una experiencia
realmente antigua la gente convivía con
diferentes lenguas que se encontraban
con diferentes lenguas de acuerdo y
tenemos la piedra rosetta que bien
sabéis la piedra que ayudó a descifrar
los jeroglíficos y tenemos tres o tres
aguas diferentes o jeroglíficos la
escritura demótica y el griego antiguo y
también en nuestro país aunque eso
parezca en estos momentos sorprendente
para algún partido político el primer
texto en castellano es un texto
trilingüe en que encontramos anotaciones
en latín en castellano una forma de
castellano antiguo
y en euskera y de hecho también esa
cuestión de interés social el hecho de
bilingüismo aquí tenéis el google en
grant que cuenta digamos la frecuencia
con la que aparecen palabras en libros y
en diferentes tipos de textos lo que
encontramos es la frecuencia relativa
con lo que aparece la palabra
bilingüismo y multilingüismo lo que
podéis ver es que a partir de los años
50 eso es el número ha ido subiendo la
frecuencia relativa la gente habla más
del fenómeno de bilingüismo
y podemos aproximar esta cuestión
haciéndolos multitud de preguntas que
algunas seguro que nos hagan venir a la
cabeza de vez en cuando por ejemplo como
un bebé como un bebé que está en una
cuna bilingüe una cuna bilingües una
cuna donde el input recibe el bebé es en
dos lenguas nos vemos el que mamá habla
una lengua papá otra o que ambos hables
al de las dos cómo se organiza el
cerebro del bebé bilingüe para separar
esas dos lenguas e ir adquiriendo los
conocimientos de cada una de ellas sin
montarse un lío descomunal es una
pregunta que podemos hacer sabemos que
la gente lo hace porque la amigos en
barcelona la mayoría de un gran número
de cunas son curas bilingües también
podemos hacer esa pregunta de cómo
afecta esa experiencia bilingüe a la
organización del lenguaje del cerebro es
decir cómo somos capaces de controlar
las dos lenguas cómo somos capaces de
hacer lo que estoy haciendo yo ahora
mismo que es controlar mi catalán
italiano mi inglés y lo de confundirme
continuamente
y qué diferencia es el cerebro tiene con
el cerebro de un hablante monolingüe
porque nosotros también preguntas
respecto a esa gimnasia continua que yo
hago cuando estoy intentando poner
riendas a los lenguajes sino mezclarlos
hasta qué punto eso es una gimnasia
mental que puede tener consecuencias
para otras actividades cognitivas como
podría ser la atención o como podría ser
el control ejecutivo podríamos
preguntarnos si esa gimnasia que hacemos
después tiene beneficios para la con lo
que llamamos la reserva cognitiva para
ser activa es el declive cognitivo que
viene asociado con la abacc y no todo el
mundo lo experimenta de igual manera
llegó el declive cognitivo que viene
asociado con las enfermedades
neurodegenerativas y no todo el mundo lo
experimenta de igual manera podríamos
ver si esa gimnasia ayuda a que ciertos
de que los cognitivos aparezcan ciertos
síntomas aparezcan más tardíamente y hoy
no vamos a hacer ninguna de esas
preguntas esa será para otra charla si
queréis hoy vamos a hacer una pregunta y
voy a introducirla con tres grandes
figuras
del siglo pasado y de este siglo y vamos
a hacer la pregunta de cómo el contexto
lingüístico puede afectar a nuestras
emociones y cómo eso puede llevar a
afectar a las decisiones que tomamos
y no hay nadie mejor que mándela cuando
nos dice eso que cuando hablas a un
hombre en una lengua que entiende el
mensaje llega a su cerebro a su cabeza y
le hablas en su lengua le llega a su
corazón
de hecho mandela aprendió la lengua del
enemigo básicamente del enemigo que lo
puso en la cárcel las de 27 años lo
aprendió justamente para poder
comunicarse con la gente que lo tenía
preso de la manera más directa
antes de bande la tenemos gente que ya
tenía una sensación de ese tipo eso que
nos dice freud y de los pacientes
cambiará su lengua foránea cuando hablan
de pasajes emocionalmente estresantes
es como si cuando yo cambio el inglés en
una situación estresante comer
digamos que me ve detalle o dehesa de
esa situación estresante es como si no
la sufrieran mira tan intensamente y ya
vemos que esta idea de que las emociones
pueden depender del contexto lingüístico
ha sido avanzado por varia gente incluso
por lo de las personas uno de los
personajes más importantes del siglo
este que es alexander costa es mi hijo
segundo estuvimos discutiendo pues no se
decía los deberes no se acaban las
judías verdes no sé lo que era entonces
yo le hablaba siempre en él en catalán y
en su momento cambia el castellano dijo
papá en castellano no y eso significa
que estás muy enfadado de acuerdo es
igual se comió la judía se castigue
bien entonces más allá del gran filósofo
alexander costa tenemos evidencia un
poquito más fina y eso es evidencia que
tenemos de uno estudio por ejemplo en el
que poner a la gente leer harry potter y
lo ponerle a leerlo en alemán la lengua
materna de estos participantes o en
inglés y miramos la activación de la
amígdala en pasajes que son
emocionalmente
multiplicamos
activada que está activa emocionalmente
y lo que encontramos es que la
activación de una estructura cerebral
que es la amígdala es una estructura que
responde mucho a situaciones emocionales
es menor cuando eso es pasa que se leen
en la lengua extranjera en la lengua
foránea a pesar de que todos los
participantes entienden lo que están
leyendo lo entienden bien no lo sienten
igual y de hecho si nos vamos a los
clásicos podemos a mirar lo que nos
decía platón aquí tenemos la cuadrilla
de platón en la que teníamos en los dos
caballos que son los impulsos positivos
y los impulsos negativos impulsos nobles
los impulsos y nobles y la razón
intentando controlar esos dos impulsos
y de hecho sabemos que las teorías
actuales de tomar decisiones hace mucho
hincapié en lo que es la intuición y lo
que es el pensamiento analítico vale
como las dos grandes fuerzas que guían
nuestras decisiones
a la intuición parecería estar muy
comentada en situaciones emocionalmente
altas
y para explicar los otros tipos de
estudios que hacemos vamos a hacer un
juego vamos a pasarnos de aquí del
cosmocaixa al casino hagan juego señores
vamos a tener un juego en el que
vosotros vais a tener que pagar un euro
para empezar a pagarlo yo después te
todos lo pagará a todos para estar un
euro y vamos a tener una moneda vamos a
jugar cara y cruz si sale cara tenéis
dos euros cincuenta
y si sale cruz me lo quedo todo yo
y que tiene jugar
quien quiere jugar 12
67 muy poca gente los otros deben estar
pensando y su abuela con la que decía
que ella más vale pájaro en mano que
ciento volando ahora bueno a veces no a
veces es más vale malo conocido que
bueno por conocer
bueno a veces no y eso lo que lo que
refleja es que si fuera es homo
economicus es decir si hiciera es el
economista si frío y racional deberíais
jugar porque el valor esperado de esta
jugada es mayor que el euro si jugábamos
muchas veces a este juego acabaríamos
ganando 125 pero vosotros tenéis lo que
se llama aversión a la pérdida aversión
al riesgo x oye mira yo me quedo del
euro y está vale eso porque sois la
mayoría de vosotros menos los que habéis
levantado la mano sois homo sapiens
nosotros son como económicos
pues bien lo que hicimos representar
estos problemas en un contexto de lengua
foránea en inglés aquí inglés de lengua
foránea me refiero una lengua que la
gente no utiliza en contextos sociales
no es aprendido y no los utiliza en
contextos sociales no es catalán y
castellano aquí sólo que sería el
castellano y el inglés que la mayoría de
nosotros lo que encontramos es que
cuando el primero la gente si quiere
jugar tenemos la lengua foránea el 70%
de la gente dice si juego
mientras que en la lengua nativa solo es
el 50% es decir la gente en una lengua
foránea tiene menos aversión a pérdida
tiene menos aversión al riesgo es más
analítica es más fría le duele más menos
el ponerse en la posibilidad de tener
una pérdida
eso es un experimento de laboratorio si
lo lleváramos a la vida real y saliera
esto tendría connotaciones muy grandes
porque todos nosotros muchas veces
tenemos que apostar cómo jugar nuestro
dinero y lo hacemos asumiendo ciertos
riesgos
pero bueno no es solo es la economía
podemos ir a cosas que decimos varios
eso de la economía de cómo jugamos el
dinero bueno a veces hoteles a veces
solo tienes lo que son los hombres de
verdad lo que tenemos el ser humano de
verdad es nuestra moral de acuerdo y eso
sí es una cosa inamovible y vamos a
comprar a dos grandes pensadores un ser
humano beckham que decía vive tu vida
como si la reacción de tus acciones se
fuera a convertir en ley universal
vale
versus una persona con diferente igual
de importante porque con diferente tipo
de visión moral que decía estos son mis
principios si ustedes le gusta aquí
tengo los otros
entonces son dos visiones de la moral
bastante diferentes pues bien aquí
decimos y llevamos al laboratorio no es
un dilema que hemos utilizado nosotros
sólo hemos inventado pero es un dilema
que se ha utilizado mucho en filosofía
moral lo adaptamos y de hecho para que
veáis que no es un dilema solo de
filosofía dejadme que os explique este
caso esto es un tren que va hacia los
ángeles y va desbocado y va a chocar
contra las estaciones más importantes de
los ángeles y lo desvían sabiendo que va
a descarrilar acaba descargando en otra
estación que acaba dañando a niños y a
gente que estaba esperando ese tren es
decir aquí tenían dos opciones o dejar
que el tren fuera y hiciera bastante
daño llegamos a la estación de los
ángeles o ser más utilitarista y
cambiarlo y hacer que unos pagarán por
otros pero menos
recuerdo y bueno básicamente lo que
hicimos hicimos este estudio en el que
presentábamos no el dibujo lo
presentábamos en texto hay un tranvía
que va desbocado ese tranvía si no se
hace nada va a matar a cinco personas no
nosotros lo ponemos que estaban
trabajando en lo que estaban haciendo la
siesta pero ahora es igual para matar a
cinco personas y tú pasas por hoy hay
una palanca puedes apretar la palanca el
tren cambiará y matar a una persona
cuántos de vosotros upl en apretar en
esa palanca
la mayor parte no
y se preguntó supongo que diréis hombre
un nuevo versos 5 aquellos que decís yo
no apretó la palanca solo realmente si
seguís sacan y decís la vida de una
persona no tiene precio y yo no tengo
por qué decidir en vuelo y quien de
acuerdo a brocha hubiera apretado a la
plancha bueno y es cierto que lo
presentamos en inglés y en castellano y
después también decimos en eeuu al revés
es lo que encontramos es que la mayoría
de la gente aprieta la palanca sorpresa
sorpresa pero entonces hicimos esta
pregunta
imagínate que va en un tren desbocado tú
vas andando por un puente y después es
un señor hay un poquito
poquito entradito en carnes y la única
manera de parar el tranvía y salvar a
las personas es empujar al señor
cuántos deportes
esos son los psicópatas o los atascos
todos respetos a los que siguen a
groucho pero es verdad si uno tiene la
visión de la respuesta anterior ha sido
un hombre sus cinco aquí esos universos
cinco pero a quien los siente igual
bueno pues nos individual depende la
idioma que te lo pregunto
resulta que si yo te pregunto es en tu
lengua nativa sólo el 20 por ciento de
la gente dice lo empujaría cuando te lo
pregunto el texto como un contexto de
lengua extranjera el 50 45 depende del
estudio 45 por ciento realmente empuja
al hombre con lo cual incluso nuestros
juicios morales pueden llegar a cambiar
dependiendo del contexto lingüístico en
el que nos encontremos yendo más allá es
presentar el último estudio sobre el
estudio simpático si queréis es un
estudio para intentar entender la
universidad y la mentira y aquí lo que
hacemos es llegar el participante a
laboratorio le damos un cubilete con un
dado y él tiene que tirar el dado las
gracias que el cliente tiene un
agujerito arriba y sólo es el equipo de
ver el dado el resultado está en una
sala que no hay ninguna que haga más
rellenada y él tiene que decir quién
nombra ha sacado dependiendo el número
que se ha quedado le damos una euro dos
tres cuatro cinco o seis dependiendo el
nombre que haya sacado
tal sabemos que en general al final de
todo el experimento tenemos que tener el
mismo número de unos entonces de 13
porque el dado no está tocado si tenemos
más 6 s es que alguien está
haciéndose el listillo pues bien ponemos
a la gente en contexto de lengua nativa
y lo que encontramos estudio en coreano
es que la gente en general se dice lo
siento de verdad es hasta un 6 están
esos números tenían que estas columnas
tienen que ser todas iguales
y lo que vemos es que no hay muchos más
veces alguien miente y cuando estemos en
lengua extranjera continúan mintiendo
pero menos
continuamente nos decimos también en
este laboratorio en nuestro laboratorio
aquí tenemos en españa es nativo 566 a
punta pala
en inglés 6 es menos de lo que cabría
esperar un poquito de 5 y está esta
distribución y se ajusta más a lo que
cabría esperar por azar creo que incluso
la honestidad puede cambiar
a estos resultados como os podéis
imaginar ha atraído la atención de mucha
gente para ver una cosa esta situación
es mucho más común de lo habitual de lo
que creemos la gente interactuando en
diferentes lenguas y más allá diferentes
tenemos no sólo que los dos sean
foráneos
sino que yo puedo estar entrar cuando
con un inglés elin su lengua nativa y yo
la extranjera no como eso puede afectar
a mis decisiones y por tanto lo que os
por eso os he dicho principio la charla
que yo espero que esta charla cambie la
manera que crees que tomas decisiones y
las cosas que en principio podrían ser
irrelevantes que se están afectando o sé
que cuando estés discutiendo con
vuestros amigos con vuestra pareja pues
estoy negociando en vuestras empresas
recordad siempre en qué contexto
lingüístico estáis porque se puede
alterar el tipo de decisión que toméis y
si no vosotros como mínimo toda esta
gente de acuerdo toda esta gente está
decidiendo por nosotros en bruselas y lo
está haciendo algunos en su lengua
nativa y otros se subleva foránea muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]